what's been your favorite oh this is
even I want to know this yeah what's
been your favorite Jamie and Claire
scene from Outlander so far this season
or like in life oh wow ever ever
different uh I mean I guess it's just
there's love a lot of love Yeah Lander
yeah um and people love how you love Sam
they love to love Jamie and Claire they
they're a little bit Inseparable um you
know it always goes back to season one
you know the wedding I think is uh you
know new love right people falling in
love yeah and I think that's why this
movie is so adorable because it's about
two people finding love again
I saw how you did that yeah you're so
smart yeah